hi everyone I'm Steve Brenton from the
University of Washington and this is an
overview in a new video series I'm
calling an introduction to data science
or intro to data science so data science
is becoming a ubiquitous part of science
engineering industry technology really
it's a part of all of our lives and what
this short video lecture sequence is
going to do is just kind of give a brief
introduction and overview to the various
aspects of data science including kind
of how to ask and answer questions with
data data basing you know how do you
manage data what's the nature of data
what types of data do you have
visualizing analyzing modeling data so
things like machine learning building
models from data neural networks and and
lots more okay and so in this overview I
just want to kind of tell you what
you're gonna see and what some of my
goals are for you and for for the
sequence so I'll just start with some
goals like I said one of my my primary
goals is for this to be an overview I'm
not gonna get into all of the nuts and
bolts and nitty gritty about every type
of machine learning or visualization in
fact I'm going to keep things pretty
high-level and pretty kind of general
I'm going for a big picture so that you
know where to look that's important I
want you to know where to look for more
so if you want to dig deeper into
something I want to point you to the
resources I want you to know what things
are called kind of a terminology
terminology so kind of how to just be
basically literate in data science and
machine learning what's the difference
between a neural network and a different
machine learning algorithm terminology
is really important to know where to
look and in this overview in addition to
that I want us to be thinking about how
to ask and answer questions how to ask
the right questions how to ask and
answer the right questions and that's
very subjective so I'll put it in quotes
the right questions okay part of that is
understanding where your data has value
and where it doesn't
so understanding the value of data the
value of data that's really important so
a lot of people are just collecting more
and more and more data and we have to
ask is it the right data does it answer
the questions that are actually
important for me okay and I kind of want
you to be excited so I'm very very
excited about just the prospects of what
you can do in data science in this kind
of data-driven revolution so data
science is pushing the boundaries of
what we can do in lots of fields of
science and engineering and technology
and industry and so I want you to be
excited about the opportunity and I also
want you to understand what are the
challenges because this is not a panacea
or a silver bullet it's not like
everything is now easy because of data
science there are major challenges that
go along with these opportunities so
that's a lot of goals but really just
giving you a high level overview being
literate with what the different
techniques in data science are and
getting you excited about the
opportunities and challenges in data
science and what I want to really want
to emphasize is in my opinion the data
science is about you know it's not
devoid of human experts it's a tool for
human experts just like theory
mathematics and experiments and
simulations are tools for humans
data science complements those
disciplines those all generate
tremendous amounts of data and data
science is now a new field of science
that is motivated by data intensive
inquiry
and study so so questions you know in
the hands of an expert human are
critical so what questions are we gonna
ask and how can those questions be
answered increasingly with data okay so
how how do those questions get answered
with data and then from my data how do I
then refine the questions I'm asking
maybe I ask new questions maybe I wasn't
asking the right question in the first
place and so there's this very
interesting feedback cycle between
asking questions and answering them with
data and so that really is the heart of
data science that's what we're gonna
talk about this is going to include how
to you know collect and clean and store
your data what is the nature of your
data what types of data might you see is
it big data or small data is it you know
sparse is the time series things like
that we're gonna talk about how to
visualize your data how to model and
analyze your data with techniques in
machine learning okay and so the way I'm
gonna run this is you know each of those
big categories there might be a five or
10 minute overview that kind of like
this gives you the lay of the land and
then there will be kind of deeper dives
so for example in machine learning we'll
talk about the principles of machine
learning and then we'll start to dig
into you know the the more nuts and
bolts aspects different methods
different types of data different
categories of machine learning so I'm
really excited to kind of take you
through this intro to data science again
this is not comprehensive this is not
complete this field is changing very
fast but I think this will give you a
good overview and and kind of get you
excited and help you figure out where to
look for more all right thank you